the project that the New York Times was
given a Pulitzer for this year of
recasting the history of the United
States in terms of slavery as the
primary narrative the 1619 project seems
to me just to be fundamentally
historically wrong it's a distortion
this isn't to say that slavery but
didn't matter it doesn't mean it's not
important it's just that if you were to
try to explain the significance of the
United States to a visiting Martian yeah
you wouldn't start with slavery because
that wasn't really an especially unique
feature of the United States there was
slavery and it lasted much longer in
Brazil there were slavery and it was far
harsher in the Caribbean colonies of
Britain and other European states so
what's the defining characteristic
what's the thing that makes the United
States distinctive it's not slavery
[Music]
from a historians perspective what do
you think that the average American
should know about the history of America
that we don't know or that we under
appreciate because you know we seem to
live in a time where we're we're erasing
our own history and we're taking down
monuments and we're you know destroying
the names of people that were flawed but
that were just people of their time well
I think the the challenge here is that
history is not it's not monochrome the
history of any Great Society or state
can't be told as a eulogy Norton or as a
kind of criminal indictment and the good
historian of the United States or for
that matter of the United Kingdom
acknowledges that there are debits as
well as credits that there is there's
shadow those dark sides to the story as
well as bright sides and this is a
challenge that I didn't think was
difficult when I was writing early in my
career I wrote history of the British
Empire which included a chapter on the
American Revolution and the book sets
out very plainly there are many stains
on the history of the British Empire
including of course the the central role
of slavery in the in the southern
colonies that became the southern states
of the United States but the points of
that book and I'd make the same argument
about the history of the United States
is that the the benefits outweighed the
costs that the successes were more
important ultimately than the failures
the project that the New York Times was
given a Pulitzer for this year of
recasting the history of the United
States in terms of slavery as the
primary narrative the 1619 project seems
to me just to be fundamentally
historically wrong it's a distortion
this isn't to say that slavery had
didn't matter it doesn't mean it's not
important it's just that if you were to
try to explain the significance of the
United States to a visiting Martian yeah
you wouldn't start
with slavery because that wasn't really
an especially unique feature of the
United States there was slavery in it
lasted much longer in Brazil there were
slavery and it was far harsher in the
Caribbean colonies of Britain and other
European states so what's the defining
characteristic what's the thing that
makes the United States distinctive it's
not slavery any more than if you looked
at Western civilization broadly it would
be true to say that imperialism's the
defining characteristic everybody did
Empire just as slavery goes way back
before 1619 all the way to ancient times
and by the way still exists there is
still slavery there are slave markets
where people are sold there are slave
economies which rely on slave labor
today so it can't really be true to say
that the interesting thing the thing you
really need to know about the United
States is slavery but the interesting
thing about the United States is that it
represented an experiment in governance
a radical experiment based on ideas from
the Enlightenment and earlier ideas from
the Protestant Reformation it's fair to
say and and this produced an
extraordinary Constitution which has
stood up to all the stresses and strains
of of history since the late 18th
century and understanding that peculiar
Constitution that very distinctive
document with its separation of powers
and its careful preservations of
individually buddy that should be your
top priority if you're studying American
history not to the exclusion of the bad
stuff there's plenty of bad stuff that
we need to study but I don't think we
should be teaching young Americans from
Howard Zinn's people's history of the
united states in which the negatives are
constantly emphasized over the positives
that just seems to me to miss the points
of the American story completely are you
worried that the
ordinary pressures that were facing
right now between a pandemic between
riots and protests between you know
polarization that really is is off the
charts and then throw in social media
which is just gas on the flame are you
worried that those pressures could snap
that project in a way that it hasn't
been snapped before or certainly in the
last 100 years let's say they've let me
give you a somewhat surprising answer
that question I'd be worried if we
weren't worried one of the things about
this country that's very distinctive is
that we're always worried that the
Republic's gonna end we're always kind
of fretting about about the coming
tyranny the impending Civil War and and
thus far there's been one civil war and
and no dictatorships and that's kind of
encouraging I think that's partly
because we worry about is and I think
it's a healthy feature of American life
also to expect decline people have been
predicting the decline of the United
States throughout my life it was a
preoccupation of Henry Kissinger whose
biography I'm in the midst of of writing
in the 1970s it seems as if the United
States was being torn apart by Vietnam
torn apart by its racial divisions torn
apart by a president who had violated
his his oath of office all of that we've
seen before and I I think it's part of
the way the United States works that
we're always expecting that
disintegration of the Republic and the
descent into civil war and I think we'll
have to start being nervous if we stop
worrying about that stuff but as long as
we have my old friend Andrew Sullivan so
fretful about the coming from tyranny
that he doesn't quite spot the tyranny
of the left until it's right up behind
him I mean that that's kind of the
predicament that I think a lot of
liberals and conservatives find
themselves in that they were so
indignant and dismayed by Trump back in
2016 that they slightly underestimated
the the rather more operationally
worrying tyrannical tendencies of the
the radical left so yeah
I think we should keep worrying about
this stuff and as long as we're worrying
about it we'll probably be okay yeah
does it also strike you as as odd or
maybe obvious relative to social media
that when something happens here that it
suddenly happens everywhere I mean we've
all seen the the videos now of literally
police officers in London being hunted
down by mobs that has nothing to do in
any concrete sense with what happened to
George Floyd and yet it seems like if
there's an incident here it's now
exported everywhere I think future
historians will wonder why it was that
in the midst of a pandemic which is far
from over
Americans decided to have a debate about
police violence towards African
Americans not not to say that that's not
an important issue to think about but it
seems an odd time to have that debate
and to start debates about defunding the
police when we should really be
wondering what went wrong with the
Department of Health and Human Services
and CDC when they ought to have taken
far better and earlier action to contain
the contagion there's something strange
it's a non sequitur that in the midst of
this massive public health crisis which
has killed nearly a hundred and twenty
thousand Americans and will probably
kill another hundred and twenty thousand
before the end of the year were having
this this debate but the second point
I'd make is that the Internet has
created a new kind of contagion as I
said earlier quoting my son there are
two pandemics and the second pandemic in
fact predates the murder of of George
Floyd because it's a pandemic of
protests that you could actually see in
Hong Kong in Santiago in Barcelona in
cities like Beirut last year and what is
interesting to me is that the mode of
protest is consistently the same the
content varies from place to place but
this quality of protest to go viral
styles of protests to be cop copied from
Hong
gong to Minneapolis is really
interesting I mean historically the
police had better communications than
demonstrators for most of the second
half of the 20th century that the police
had walkie-talkies and the demonstrators
were lucky if they had mega phones but
the smartphone has changed that and it's
allowed protesters to really organize
these a setlist networks where there is
no obvious leader and actually if
superior comes to the police if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist there all
right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell